the forecast for sunday is temperatures
in the single digits wind chill below
zero
how does that impact preparations for
the game and perhaps yeah we're looking
outside for the chiefs whatever it is it
is
do you mind playing in severe cold
i'd love to plan a championship game
schedule wherever you want
the always chatty and personable bill
belichick talking about the conditions
that are expected on sunday in kansas
city and chris i'm looking at
weather.com right now single digits no
more i see a high of 27 and a low of 22.
that is a far cry from the forecast that
we saw earlier in the week and i think
that benefits the chiefs very low chance
of precipitation seven mile per hour
winds
i think that if you don't have a deep
freeze that's one less factor that could
potentially keep patrick mahomes from
being patrick mahomes yeah i mean i
agree with that i mean first of all i
think the patriots when you really watch
them they're a run first team that's
what they want to do we all saw what
they did the chargers last week it was
you know pound the rock pound the rock
then play action pass by brady that was
really their game plan throughout and
it's been their game plan all year long
so yes cold weather uh inability to
throw the ball i do think would favor
the patriots now that we're getting
towards the temperatures we saw last
week with the colts game while we were
there you know and of course there's
gonna be no snow or anything like that
this time around i do think that favors
more of the high-powered pass offense
mike you ever notice how bill let me
just ask you this you ever notice how
bill seems to be more personable on the
phone call conference calls like and
then yet when he's on camera he's he's a
different guy in the interviews like
where he's more direct like we just saw
him there but he did he did a kansas
city press conference call earlier this
week and i felt like he was so much more
charismatic i mean i don't know i'm just
throwing that out there
you're the guy that worked in the same
building with him i think there is a
stew of quirks and eccentricities with
bill belichick and if you put him on
camera those tend to manifest themselves
a little bit more i'm not trying to
psychoanalyze the guy yeah but i just
don't think he's comfortable and what
look what we look what we saw with adam
gase yeah at his introductory press
conference with all the cameras wearing
the suit with all these faces that he'd
never seen before and being in an
uncomfortable situation yeah it's more
comfortable when you don't have that
camera staring at every move you make
and i think that's part of the
discomfort that we see in bill belichick
plus i also think he is committed to not
saying anything that will in any way
affect his strategic goals and
objectives and in any way make it easier
for his opponent to overcome his team i
think that's part of it as well yeah i
get that too and bill is like i mean
he's extremely
eccentric like you said i mean there was
moments mike where i would be in the
patriots facility and it would be 8 30
at night and i'd be walking down the
hallway and it was just me and bill
and i would say hello coach and he would
look up like he had no idea we were
walking by each other because he was so
deep in thought and thinking about game
planning or whatever it was and then it
was like oh wait hey chris how are you i
mean that's what wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute you would say hello
to coach belichick he wouldn't get your
standard greeting the one that you can
never use on the air no nope i uh you
never tried that one i think you would
have got a reaction from him if he would
have used that greeting yeah probably
you're right but no i i never threw that
out there to coach belichick i did not
yeah all right let's throw out some of
the specific matchups that will be a
factor on sunday when the patriots and
the chiefs get together at arrowhead
stadium and chris give me yours what
what's the number one match-up that
stands out to you as as being relevant
to the outcome of this game well i think
like you just talked about we talked
about the weather and you know now it's
a little bit better for the the chiefs
pass offense the first thing i look at
of course is
and i'm sure bill belichick's the same
way as how do we defend tyreek hill
right and then everything kind of
filters off from there but the stephon
gilmore tyree kill matchup is what i
expect it to be because the patriots
love to play man-to-man coverage and
gilmore arguably the best corner in
football this year the way he played and
last week what he did to keenan allen
other than the pump and go that we saw
for the touchdown that scored the first
seven for the chargers he absolutely
shut down keenan allen keenan allen
could not do anything so i think that
matchup and the other reason i'm
intrigued with that matchup mike is
because if they go there then you know
how does it go down the rest of the line
as far as who matches up with kelsey who
matches up with sammy watkins in certain
situations but i do think that will be
the big matchup hill vs gilmore we know
hill is probably he is the fastest most
explosive receiver in football they use
him in so many different ways and are
they going to leave gilmore on an island
all game long and just let him play
man-to-man uh are they going to move
gilmore off of him and put him on sammy
watkins or maybe double team tyree kill
with two other guys i just don't know
where it goes but either way i'm
extremely interested to see how bill
plays tyrique you know you see here this
is a single safety zone coverage if
you're watching on tv he throws a deep
post down the middle of the tyre kill it
was zone tyreek found the zone mahomes
throws a rifle in there and then the
safety can't make the play in space i
think they're gonna have to be careful
about letting him play in space and zone
coverages a little bit in this time this
time around
have you noticed anything in studying
film of the chiefs as it relates to
teams using defensive backs aggressively
at the line of scrimmage to try to
disrupt hill's timing just slow him down
keep him from getting that explosion off
the line of scrimmage yeah and and i
know because we we talked about this a
little last week right a little bit with
i heard rodney harrison talking about it
as well and you know no and this is the
reason why i think people like even when
jaylen ramsey jaylen ramsey got his
hands on tyree kill a few times jaylen
ramsey you know he's special player too
and maybe gilmore can do this as well um
but i think the other thing you have to
be worried about and i saw this even
when jalen ramsey matched up with them
was when they try to be physical at the
line of scrimmage and you miss mike
right then it's oh no he's gone by me
and i'm in a horrible position and
there's no way i'm going to catch up
because he is the fastest player in
football so you have to be very picky
and choosy about how aggressive or when
you might want to be aggressive it has
to be i think a once in a while sneak
attack type thing if you think you're
going to jam him consistently all game
long he's quick he's going to make you
miss and then that could be you know a
60-yard bomb over your over the over
your head
and it's an amazing combination to have
the straight-line speed but also the
ability to avoid that
nfl caliber defensive back who is across
from you intent on hitting you
disrupting you and if you have the
agility and the explosion at the line of
scrimmage to avoid that guy and get past
him completely then yeah you run down
the field completely unfettered and you
know one of the matchups that i think is
important it's a bigger picture offense
versus defense because we talk about oh
patrick mahomes versus tom brady no it's
patrick mahomes versus bill belichick
that's right what will belichick do big
picture and the tyree kill component is
just part of it what do you trot out to
confuse patrick mahomes can you confuse
patrick mahomes i mean the problem with
with a defense facing mahomes is that if
you do stymie what they're trying to do
what the plan is when it breaks down
he's just as good as when he's running
the plan yes like if it all becomes
chaos and he can't do the the reads he's
supposed to do and it just becomes
backyard sandlot football he's unlike
any other quarterback in the league now
or perhaps ever at making something
happen and how do you plan for that
right like hey here's what we're gonna
do
and uh when it all goes to hell uh do
your best to not make a full out of
yourself and me i mean what can you
really do at that point yeah i mean
that's a valid point mike i mean and
that is that is
patrick mahomes is the type of guy that
drives bill belichick and the new
england patriots defensive coach is
crazy because there's you know he has
the talent like you're saying that you
can't game plan for and we've seen new
england have little issues with these
type of players i mean you know hey
russell wilson's two and one against new
england i know he lost the big one in
the super bowl we've seen desean watson
and the magic he can make against new
england i believe cam newton has a
winning record against new england you
know aaron rodgers is one-on-one against
new england because it's those type of
guys where oh okay we got the offensive
scheme stopped but now we can't stop
them in the pocket when the play breaks
down and then their talents overtake you
know our scheme and then there's nothing
we can do the first matchup mike i'll
just say this they did their best to not
let him run right and other than the
touchdown where he rolled right and
threw the perfect bomb down the sideline
to kareem hunt they made it very hard on
him they kept dante hightower kind of
right at the center line of scrimmage
and as soon as mahomes wanted to break
to his right dante hightower a lot of
times was there right as he was doing it
and if you remember mahomes throws the
interception at the end of the first
half in the end zone as they're down in
scoring position and kind of has dante
hightower dragging on his back as he's
throwing it i think that's one thing
they're gonna look at with mahomes mike
and i think it's a great point by you is
they're gonna go
okay he's gonna get out of the pocket
let's not him go let's not let him go
right let's make him go left which we
know he's still amazing but not as
amazing going left as he is right
and this is where the film study i think
becomes an issue both as it relates to
mahomes and as it relates to the
patriots defense because i think if i'm
bill belichick the challenge is
to find a look that i can give to
mahomes that will make him think that
we're going to do something that we
don't do and somebody pops up in the
right spot right intercepts a pass when
he thinks he's getting before it breaks
down right dupe him into thinking that
there's going to be something there and
somebody swoops over and grabs the ball
and that pops the bubble early and then
it puts some doubt in his head going
forward that may be it psychologically
may be the only way to beat a guy who
physically is better than anyone we've
seen that's right and mike to that point
you that's what they did in the first
match remember the first interception he
threw kind of across the field and dante
hightower caught it he did they did
exactly that they disguised they made it
look like dante hightower was going to
blitz and then he backed out and mahomes
had not really seen anything like that
he thought oh okay i got you know travis
kelsey coming across the formation i'm
gonna hit this and then all of a sudden
it was oh no there's dante hightower so
i do i mean i agree they're gonna try to
do their best to confuse them and it's
also one of the reasons i say kansas
city read mahomes it's great that
they're getting a second look at this
defense because you know mahomes the
first time i think was a little shell
shocked in the first half about things
they did to him and the confusion and i
think he'll feel a little bit more
comfortable this time around kind of
knowing how they attacked him and
knowing that he's seen more defenses and
and different ways he was attacked as
the year went on
and he was sailing the ball early in
that game back in week six he settled
down dramatically in the second half and
made it into a shootout but the patriots
were in position to run away with it
after the first half and to his credit
my homes got it together and later in
the program on the tv side for nbcsn and
sky sports you will see chris sims break
down some of these plays he's been
talking about as to how the patriots
confused mahomes back in week six let's
get one more in chris and let's flip it
over to the patriots when they have the
ball and the chiefs are on defense give
me a key match up in that setting that
patriots run game versus the front four
of the kansas city chiefs and their
d-line you know
we talked about in the opening just how
the patriots are a run first team and
it's a complex run game it's one of the
most complex run games there is in the
nfl they can do so many different things
traps pulling guards wham plays you know
toss plays they do it all and what
really i say the chiefs d-line you know
they're gonna have to handle it
themselves for the most part i know the
linebackers and everybody gonna have to
help out but what i'm saying is you know
the chiefs are gonna have to be careful
about how many secondary people
they try to put into the let's stop the
run you know basket there because if
they start doing that then you're going
to see the play action passes like we
did last week so if that front four can
kind of handle the run game by itself
with limited help from safeties in the
box and things like that i think that
will be a big key to the football game
for the chiefs to play you know more
coverage and help out their weak
secondary in the back end so they don't
get exposed there mike
all right and that is a great assessment
of what can happen when the patriots
have the ball and and really as that as
that predicted mercury number gets
higher and higher it uh it may be a
little less important and and that again
plays to the chiefs
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports